ابو عبيده حي المقاومه في لبنان واليمن
والعراق ومناطق اخرى ونعى شهدائهم وقال
انه جاءت رسائل من جبهات المقاومه تشير
الى توسيع عملياتها في الايام القادمه مع
استمرار العدوان على
غزه نحيي الايدي الضاربه الوفيه من مقاتلي
امتنا في لبنان العطاء والبطوله وفي يمن
الحكمه والايمان وفي العراق وفي كل ساحات
امتنا ونعى الى امتنا شهدائهم ونبارك
جهدهم
وعطائهم والعالم يرى كيف هرعت قوى الظلم
وشكلت التحالفات واستدعت زبانيه النفاق
والغطرسة
وراءه ولا يزالون لكمات كبيره وضربات
مباركه وقوفا في وجه المحرقه النازيه
الصهيونيه ضد شعبنا
واهلنا واننا اذ ابلغنا من جهات عده في
جبهات المقاومه بانهم سيوسع ضرباتهم للعدو
في قابل الايام في ظل استمرار العدوان على
غزه فاننا لن نكل ولن نمل في دعوه كل
احرار الامه ان يهبوا لنصره اقصاه
ومسرى نبيهم الذي يسير الصهاينه المجرمون
في خطوات عمليه لهدمه واقامه هيكلهم